Somehow, we made it through Ramadan
2026, and no one told me until the end
that a US governor had put out a
seriously disturbing proclamation for
his state. We're going to read it, but
first, if you're not familiar with
Ramadan, it's a month when Muslims gorge
themselves with food multiple times per
day, but skip lunch, and they call it
fasting, and they want the entire world
to praise them for fasting, even though
they're feasting, not fasting.
If you're in the US, think of
Thanksgiving dinner. If you're in some
other country, think of a holiday where
you eat a big meal.
Now, imagine eating that big meal every
night and every morning for an entire
month. That's basically Ramadan. Muslims
consume more food during Ramadan than
they consume in other months. They gain
weight while they're fasting. They end
up with all sorts of medical problems
because of the binge eating.
But, we're not going to criticize it
because criticism is Islamophobic. Let's
check out this proclamation from
Governor Josh Stein. Josh Stein is North
Carolina's first Jewish governor. You
see, they're trying to destroy Islam.
Oh, wait, he's actually promoting Islam
in North Carolina.
State of North Carolina, apparently at
the earliest stage of becoming a Sharia
compliant hellhole, good to have goals,
though. Josh Stein, governor. Ramadan
2026.
By the governor of the state of North
Carolina, a proclamation.
Whereas, North Carolina is home to more
than 130,000
Muslims,
there are more than 11 million people in
North Carolina, so 130,000 Muslims would
be a little over 1% of the population.
But, don't worry. 1% of the population
is plenty for politicians to start
groveling.
Whereas, North Carolina is home to more
than 130,000
Muslims, and whereas Muslim Americans
are one of the most racially diverse
groups in the US, comprising African
Americans, Asians, Arabs, Africans,
Latinos, and Caucasians,
why is he bringing race into this?
Especially when he's talking about a
religion that convinces people that the
creator of the universe wants them to
live and think and dress and eat and
walk and talk and even go to the
bathroom like 7th century Arabs.
It's an Arab supremacist religion.
If Islam's final prophet had been born
in Japan, Muslims would be wearing
kimonos and eating with chopsticks and
memorizing prayers in Japanese.
And whereas, Islamic traditions and
values serve as an inspiration and
reflection for the millions of
individuals who look to the teachings of
Islam for guidance,
Islamic traditions and values? Like not
being friends with Jews or Christians?
Sura 5, verse 51. Oh, you who believe,
do not take the Jews and the Christians
for friends. They are friends of each
other, and whoever amongst you takes
them for a friend, then surely he is one
of them. Surely, Allah does not guide
the unjust people.
What about Jews and Christians being the
worst of creatures? Sura 98, verse 6.
Verily, those who disbelieve in the
religion of Islam, the Quran, and
Prophet Muhammad, blah, blah, blah, from
among the people of the scripture, Jews
and Christians, and al-mushrikun,
mushrikun are people who associate
partners with Allah, will abide in the
fire of hell. They are the worst of
creatures.
What about violently subjugating Jews
and Christians? Sura 9, verse 29. Fight
those who do not believe in Allah, nor
in the latter day, nor do they prohibit
what Allah and his apostle have
prohibited, nor follow the religion of
truth out of those who have been given
the book, Jews and Christians, until
they pay the tax in acknowledgement of
superiority,
and they are in a state of subjection.
What about expelling Jews and Christians
from Arabia? In Sahih Muslim 4366,
Muhammad gave his proclamation, very
different from Governor Josh Stein's
proclamation.
I will expel the Jews and Christians
from the Arabian Peninsula and will not
leave any but Muslim.
But, Muhammad was also thinking about
the future. What's the ultimate goal?
Sahih Muslim 6985.
The last hour would not come unless the
Muslims will fight against the Jews, and
the Muslims would kill them until the
Jews would hide themselves behind a
stone or a tree, and a stone or a tree
would say, "Muslim, or the servant of
Allah, there is a Jew behind me. Come
and kill him." But, the tree gharkad
would not say, for it is the tree of the
Jews.
Always wonderful to celebrate these
Islamic teachings that provide guidance
to millions of individuals.
And whereas, Ramadan, the ninth month in
the Islamic calendar, is celebrated
annually, not in the Zoot sense, by
millions of Muslims throughout the
United States and more than 2 billion
Muslims worldwide, and whereas, Ramadan
is celebrated by Muslims as a month of
feasting, sorry, fasting.
We'll call it trans fasting. It's
feasting that identifies as fasting and
demands that we call it fasting, not
feasting.
Community service and reflection, and
whereas, during the month of Ramadan,
the Muslim community across North
Carolina and the country will
collectively celebrate the revelation,
revelation? Of the Quran and its
teachings.
Got to love the Quran and its teachings.
And whereas, on behalf of the state of
North Carolina, I am proud to recognize
the contributions of Muslim Americans.
Now, therefore, I, Josh Stein, governor
of the state of North Carolina, do
hereby proclaim February 17th to March
19th, 2026 as Ramadan in North Carolina,
and command its observance to all
residents.
Command its observance to all
residents?
Command its observance to all residents?
Command its observance to all
residents?
That part by itself makes me think this
guy shouldn't be managing a lemonade
stand, let alone one of the 50 United
States of America.
In witness whereof, I have hereunto set
my hand and affixed the great seal of
the state of North Carolina at the
capital in Raleigh this 25th day of
February in the year of our Lord 2026th
and of the independence of the United
States of America, the 250th.
Wait, year of our Lord?
Which Lord are we in the 2026th
year of for this Ramadan proclamation?
Is it the same Lord who said,
"And when you fast, do not look gloomy
like the hypocrites, for they disfigure
their faces that their fasting may be
seen by others? Truly, I say to you,
they have received their reward.
But, when you fast, anoint your head and
wash your face that your fasting may not
be seen by others, but by your father
who is in secret, and your father who
sees in secret will reward you?"
That Lord?
Why do we need a proclamation for
something our Lord says shouldn't be
done for show? Especially
when they're not really doing it.
You're not supposed to fast in order to
be seen by others. Imagine what our Lord
would say about pretending to fast in
order to be seen by others as fasting.
Weird stuff.
Listen, I know that lots of politicians
want to be inclusive. I totally get
that.
But, there are limits.
If an ideology calls for your violent
subjugation and even your eventual
extermination,
probably not a good idea to commend that
ideology to all residents.
Especially to the nearly 99% of
residents
who are in its crosshairs.
It is Ramadan.
>> [music]
>> It is Ramadan.
It is Ramadan.
It is not violent.
It is Ramadan. [music]
It is Ramadan.
It is not violent. This is a powerful
religion. There's a reason [music] to
it. Yeah? Yeah? Yeah?